tasty happy glorious Tuesday and what an
amazing Tuesday it is first congrats to
Tyrus who woke up to a number one book
on Amazon where's the keys at and
congrats congrats to Kat who woke up to
a booking at Rikers Island
[Laughter]
how to the insane media response over
Elon Musk buying Twitter even Brian
stelter was pulling his hair out
sure he had to use tweezers but now his
back's as smooth as a baby's bottom I've
never seen so many opinions and so many
bad ones but that's the point you can
see them if the anti-muskers had their
way you'd only see theirs they've gotten
used to social media being their own
personal highlight reel now they're
about to get online exposure that would
make Kim Kardashian's butt jealous
it does get jealous isn't it weird that
the promasters are also the anti-muskers
they wanted to you to cover your mouths
at all times while their mouths are open
24 hours like a 7-Eleven where the
Slurpees give you cold sores
first let's listen to the dumbest take
in the universe from Ari melber
I'm just telling you this thing matters
a ton if you own all of Twitter or
Facebook or what have you you don't have
to explain yourself you don't even have
to be transparent you could secretly ban
one Party's candidate or all of its
candidates all of its nominees or you
could just secretly turn down the reach
of their stuff and turn up the reach of
something else and the rest of us might
not even find out about it until after
the election
exactly
my God where has this [ __ ] been he just
described how the left has already
manipulated social media to push hoaxes
and buried real stories like Hunter's
laptop in order to affect elections talk
about projection it's like Alec Baldwin
crashing a gun safety course and
shouting sounds like someone could get
hurt with one of these things
and he exposed the problem musk aims to
solve they're not really afraid of what
conservatives might do to them they're
afraid because they know they've been
rigging the game and now everyone else
will know it too hence the Tantrums
here's CNN's lump of mashed potatoes
lamenting Twitter's New Freedom
if you uh if you get invited to
something where there are no rules where
there is total freedom uh forever for
everybody do you actually want to go to
that party or are you going to decide to
stay home
uh yeah we're going to that party
Mr Hall Monitor
but picture this fella in high school
hey Brian it's Jennifer my parents are
away all weekend so I'm having a huge
bash in my house Saturday night you
coming or what wait Jen did you say no
adult supervision who's going to
moderate alcohol who's checking IDs is
there going to be loud music sorry I'm
gonna have to call your parents besides
there's a Star Trek documentary on
sci-fi Network
now obviously that's unrealistic Jen
would never call Brian in the first
place she only dates guys who can see
their toes
meanwhile oh
just worry that musk has now made it
unsafe for women and minorities and
worse he could bully reporters who
modestly see themselves as more
threatened than undocumented non-binary
sea turtles
some are celebrating the deal others are
concerned a hands-off approach to
content we'll make Twitter a Haven for
disinformation and hate speech musk has
used the platform to bully critics and
reporters some critics are concerned
that musk's pursuit of free speech will
collide with growing safety problems on
Twitter especially for women and
minorities uh our women and minorities
that weak that they need extra
protection from speech that's insulting
then there's the view injecting race
into it
on Twitter it is predominantly straight
white men so when Elon Musk says wow
this is about Free Speech it seems to me
that it's about free speech of straight
white men free speech for straight white
men I bet that's news to George takai
but why should you care
it's on The View which is free speech
for dumb broads
thank you Tyrus
well placed
and even before Twitter was sold Morning
Joe was about to morning blow
to me when the the richest guy in the
world takes over the most important
social media platform that's just not a
winning formula to me and it reminds me
of all Bond movies where you know Dr
Evil and guys like that or Goldfinger
we're going to take over the media uh I
just my tummy meter says there's
something just not great about this ah
musk upsets Donny's tummy
what is he five
maybe go lie down and Mommy will bring
you some Saltines daddy will be home
soon and you can show him how you went
poo poo in the toy toy instead of your
diaped up you dope dope
laughs
finally Jamila Jamil has announced she's
leaving Twitter because musk bought it
which raises the question who the hell
is Jamila Jamil
we'll tell her the same thing we tell
lefties who always say they're fleeing
to Canada don't let the door hit your
ass on the way out they're like drunks
getting thrown out of a club yelling you
just lost a customer
well how is Twitter going to survive
without a b-list English actress who's
about as popular as trans fat
so have you ever seen so many people
freak out over nothing maybe it's not
nothing maybe they should freak out
they're gagging on the taste of freedom
and for fans of free speech it doesn't
get more delicious because for so many
lazy liberals Twitter was their favorite
restaurant where they could get the best
seat in the house right by the window
and if it wasn't on the menu it didn't
exist and your opinions weren't welcome
because theirs needed protection they
tell you to go build your own restaurant
losers then they'd call the health
department to shut it down so they
needed a Velvet Rope to protect
themselves from you and now the Rope is
gone and they are not handling it well
oh that's it Twitter is dead to me I am
deleting my account all right I have
principles wow that's a big step
[Music]
we're just checking Twitter to see if
anyone noticed you left no because you
were oh my God you searched hashtag cat
quits Twitter wow zero results I was
worried okay I didn't know if people
would be okay without my fiery hot takes
sure
hey can't can I get you to take a look
at something real quick oh my God
checking Twitter on your desktop you
can't stop admit it all of this because
you hate Elon Musk what's in a lawn musk
I quit Twitter because it allows
extremists and porn and extreme porn
really and this is free yeah will you
excuse me
oh it's like to grassy High
[Laughter]
between CNN plus imploding and this
meltdown it's like Christmas in April
and while we receive freedom in our
stockings the left got a nice chunk of
fossil fuel we call coal and what a joke
the media has become they think the
solution to everything is censorship of
words ideas that's unacceptable in a
free Society but the reply of shut up
stupid no longer works intriguing
transphobic racist misogynist is falling
by the wayside too they can't control us
anymore now they're losing control of
themselves they're a clown car
overstuffed and broken down on the side
of the road watching a Tesla Zoom by so
welcome to the Freedom Party lefties I'm
the first amendment nice to finally meet
you
[Applause]
her work on Mansion Global has made her
part of our Mansion family
[Laughter]
Fox Business Casey
move
if you walked a mile in his shoes you'd
probably get athlete's foot founder of
the loftusparty.com Michael Lofton
she's on more watch lists than Game of
Thrones Fox News contributor cartoon
and I bought 50 copies of his book which
I stand on to look him in the eye my
massive sidekick and the nwa's world
Television Champion
all right I'm gonna go to you first
Tyrus for one for two things one
congratulations again on number one and
number two you mentioned to this to me
last night that you saw your Twitter
feed go up after the sale yeah Twitter
feed uh Twitter followers so I go home I
did two thousands yeah what do you make
of this well I don't tweet that much
yeah and I was playing my Xbox and I
happened to look and I was like when did
I have 400 000 what and I kept noticing
every minute 100 new followers 100 new
followers and I was like okay so dad's
coming home and they're trying to clean
up this is what they're so they either
were and they even said they adjust the
dials to see your reach or whatever
right so apparently they took young
viewership away from us because
apparently that's the demographic that's
what it looks like because most like it
was a lot of young people and stuff so I
was like yeah okay this makes sense so
there's doing a lot of cleaning up this
but this in a nutshell this is like the
guy who cheats on his wife all the time
and then you meet him at the bar and
he's destroyed because his wife cheated
on him and he's so how could she do this
to me the Betrayal like I mean yeah I
cheated but it was different I I she
talked to them and she's like I never
talked to him like you're like bruh
it's the same thing right they're
getting their own medicine and they're
really upset about it I have never seen
I don't know any other
place in the world where a billionaire
is like hey I'm gonna come help your
company and everyone will be upset about
it and then the last thing you misread
that stelter thing way wrong but he was
really trying to get that guy to hang
out with him like what if it was a party
there was no rules you could do whatever
you want there's all your favorite foods
and um you know like he even did his
voice change he did not pick up the
house and like watch movies and like I
think that was what he was trying to
find make a friend it's tough over there
he's lost a lot of friends that's true
he really needs a friend but yeah this
is this is uh wow this is what happens
when one is in charge and you get you
get demoted now they're in the pool with
the rest of us yeah I hope they can swim
and now and we're the Ruffians Casey
welcome back to the show you look
delightful thank you so much oh my
pleasure uh what do you do uh what's
your take on this whole thing it's a big
news in the media what do you what's
your impression as a woman I felt unsafe
on Twitter since I joined like in 2008
Jesus I mean what did I do yeah but no I
mean the left loved Elon Musk I mean he
gave us electric cars right and if you
couldn't afford gas just go buy a Tesla
I mean that works for everybody buy two
if you want and now he's this evil super
villain and they're like oh Wookie has
ties to China just listen to Jeff Bezos
but then Jeff Bezos says actually maybe
not I don't know I think it's just this
vicious cycle and and it's a taste of
their own medicine to your point Tyrus
and
yeah do you uh is there anything you
want to change any like any products I
kind of hate the edit button oh you hate
it I think so I don't know but I would
miss your tweets cat thank you my tweets
are very good
and I really just feel bad for all the
people that were missing out on all my
hot takes all this I know and they're
all like young go-getters I'm sure yes
not just men in their 70s interested in
your feet no but where would I be
without those guys nowhere without me
without your feet nowhere you would be
defeated I get what you want wow boom
triple word score he worked for that one
yes
someone on the show is nice to me
I love you people we're cat ladies
everybody's nice to you here that's so
that's so true Greg
what do you wait anything else analysis
wise yeah yeah I'm talking to you and
looking at you yeah uh that's what I do
for a living uh it's been the best to
see how many people are quitting and
being like okay well now it's just
Instagram because like a billionaire
doesn't own that one it's just people
don't pay attention to anything except
what the outrage is of the day and
they're like these people are pissed so
I'm gonna be us you know osmosis I'm
gonna be pissed as well to prove what a
good person I am but I don't think
anyone's Really Gonna care it's not like
me living Twitter which of course would
devastate everyone no it would it would
be quite uh um Michael sir how do you
feel about this are you cheering are you
I'm loving every second of it yeah but I
will find something to [ __ ] about
please do because like like so great
Elon Musk came in because everyone knew
that there was an algorithm and voices
were being dialed down and Others May
being Amplified and they were using it
like a laser pointer with cats yeah you
know hey follow this story that's the
important one not that don't do that oh
get away Mr President oh look over here
it's it was all horrible and yet our
government was standing by and doing
nothing and you know like when the
Hunter's laptop story was made to go
away and other voices were Amplified
that's directly affecting our elections
our as Nancy Pelosi would say I sacred
democracy Elon Musk has to come in and
save the day and do this which is a real
letdown but I'm loving the freak out
it's like that scene in Caddyshack when
they let all the caddies swim in the
pool and everybody's just flipping out
it's great yes I never saw that movie
but I know what you're talking about you
ever saw Caddyshack I think I did but I
was you know I don't know if I was sober
hey do me a favor have somebody have
Gene write down the name of everyone who
leaves Twitter so we can do a whole show
about how they're coming back to fight
the good fights oh yes I stepped away
but yeah
that's about to be back I also love the
people on Twitter who are like so he'll
spend billions on this but he didn't
clean the creek like he's America's
handyman yeah yeah hey you spent your
money on that what about my cat had a
hairball it's great yeah you had 40
iPhones in a year sir like and also like
it was uh what Casey said it was like he
go like people going imagine how much
that money could have been spent on
climate change the guy makes electric
cars you idiots he could do this yeah
anyway before we go a quick announcement
oh that sounded like bad news
come see me on my book tour Saturday May
21st at the Eccles theater in Salt Lake
City I wonder if that's related to Teddy
Eccles who's that he was an actor from
the 70s Tyrus will be there for a meet
and greet and book signing Teddy Eccles
used to be in weird TV shows he was like
a like I've never seen a cattle Shack
but I'll talk about Teddy Eckles get
tickets at gcuffbelt.com it's
May 21st hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else